global's survivor is back with more
blindsides backstabbing and bloodshed
than ever before in its 42nd season
yeah and things got off to a quick start
during last night's premiere as the
tribes took part in the all-important
marooning challenge and as we know in
this new era of survivor the twists and
turns come at a castaway's fate yes and
uh that was the case for
uh drya lindsay and hai who got the
choice to either continue on in the
challenge as normal or work together to
earn an advantage in the game
yeah so of course it was a no-brainer
and they went for it but things got
messy as they try to cover up their lie
what's the lie
to cover up your life spread mud and
fake blood over your body this isn't too
bad
okay let's help each other out here
yo this one is a long ride
a yeah time to give back
rest of the tribe can do nothing until
their tribe member is back with those
two paddles this is mud get in there
[Music]
oh it's so cute but sorry they're gonna
be like what kind of put it on my face
too freaking the hospital looks like
it's believable otherwise it's like you
can't just
no one's back yet i've been on such a
strict skincare routine this is good oh
yeah you're right oh my god i hope
you're okay
[Music]
wow this is a hell of a run you said
come on jeff
oh my god come on no you have to we're
not bleeding okay okay i'll do that
like we have to go this doesn't this
doesn't look good at all
all right and now we are joined with our
special survivor correspondent and
season 41 winner erica katsupinen hello
erica how are you hi roz hi keisha i'm
so excited so you
canada's first survivor winner how did
you even wind up on survivor well i
actually saw on et canada that canadians
were eligible to be on the show so i
sent in an application i ended up
winning survivor and now i'm back on et
canada to talk about survivor it's quite
the full circle
yes we'd love to see it so we have to
talk about that challenge how important
are these decisions in the game what was
going through the castmates minds well
survivor is a game made up of decisions
and what was interesting about the twist
at the challenge is that they had to
make a decision on the spot during the
challenge with their competitors who
they've never met before and who have to
go back and live on other tribes so
there's a lot of things they need to
think about here they have to think
about one do i take the advantage
two what information am i revealing
about myself to my competitors three am
i really able to trust these people and
then you also have to think about how to
make it believable so i thought it was
hilarious that the show gave them this
blood well fake blood and this mud that
they're supposed to wipe all over their
bodies to somehow explain how they've
been gone for so long and you even have
to think about is my placement of fake
blood going to look real okay so later
on in the episode we found out that the
advantage uh dre sorry drea lindsey and
high received in the challenge was an
actual amulet but that all three parts
of the amulet must be played together
however the fewer amulets in the game
the more power they have so walk us
through
all of this because it is absolutely
insane so let me preface this by saying
i love survivor and i have one survivor
and this is a confusing advantage
because there are three amulets that
with people on different tribes and
they're only going to work when the
three people with an amulet come back
together which means for example they
all need to make the merge that's one
thing that needs to happen now if
depending on the number of amulets that
are in the game it affects whether or
not they're powerful or they get a
better advantage so if there are three
amulets then that means that
somebody can
the three of them can work together and
they can have an extra vote if there's
two amulets then they represent a steal
a vote advantage and if there's one
amulet then it's an idol which is the
ultimate advantage on survivor so now it
becomes a bit crazy because these three
probably established that they would be
able to trust each other when they were
in the challenge making that decision
but when they meet up and hopefully they
do meet up later in the game and they
have to decide are they going to shoot
each other and who is shooting first and
i predict when they get back together
it's going to be a bit of a war okay
okay so of course we see the eca tribe
win the challenge which earns them their
camp essentials but you know which is
like flint a pot i'm a machete but the
other two tribes had to work for it by
taking part in the sweat or savvy
challenge and both tribes chose savvy a
visual triangle riddle where you only
get two guesses erica do you think that
was the right move like how did this
challenge differ from the one on your
season
i think that this was the right move and
they they did change the challenge a
little bit since survivor 41 because
on my season two people would have to do
the sweat part versus on season 42 there
would only be one person on my season
the savvy triangle puzzle would require
only one guess whereas on survivor 42
they get two so i do think that the
difference really
it came to life in terms of the decision
making with the competitors and what i
liked about it is now
we are able to see them work together
we're not going to have a few people who
are isolated so we get to get more
insight into their tribe dynamics and we
get to get more insight into mentally
how these players are approaching the
problems that are posed to them okay we
have to talk about jackson who told his
tribe mates that he was transgender and
that he didn't want to hide his true
self from the team but later on in the
episode jeff probst makes a surprise
visit which usually is never a good sign
yeah so jeff shared that during the
casting process jackson disclosed new
medical info a day before they started
shooting and although they thought it
would be okay for him to take part in
the game that wasn't so much the case
anymore erica walk us through what
happened
yeah so jackson explained that he had
been trying to get off lithium figuring
that he would be fine by the time the
game began and to clarify he wasn't on
it because of his transition rather
because of the stress of taking care of
his mom and after candidly opening up
and the hopes of erasing the stigma jeff
noted that there will be side effects
due to the game's stress dehydration and
starvation and since the drug might be
in his system it was too dangerous for
him to continue wow
we've seen people leave for medical
reasons before but this is really a
first right it is i don't think we've
seen anything like this on survivor what
do they want to know from you before you
go in as far as medical stuff how deep
do you have to do you have to go in that
process we do a lot of medical tests
before we get to the island there's a
lot of checkups with the doctor once
we're on the island right before we
start filming so it's very thorough
wow okay lastly we of course have to
talk about zach and the fact that he
used his shot in the dark during tribal
council okay i was not expecting that
during the first episode
yeah the shot in the dark advantage it's
relatively new to the survivor world and
really i think that zach played it
correctly once the votes were read all
of the votes were that were for zach so
he didn't really have
whether or not he voted it wasn't going
to change anything and him taking that
chance with the shot in the dark even
though it's a low probability still
increased his odds from zero to 16
percent i think that you know
he still ended up picking the wrong
scroll so it didn't work out for him but
i had talked to him earlier today he
talked about the telltale signs that he
couldn't trust what people were saying
to him at camp so i think he made the
right call it just didn't work out
all right thank you so much erica uh
well erica is here keisha anything you
want to know about survivor any of the
inside stuff
yes okay so as a canadian who won
with your earnings are you taxed the
same as if you were an american you
don't gonna tell me the amount what the
senator should be talking did you take
home
so it is so confusing i have a bunch of
very smart accountants working on
but it seems like i'm setting a
precedent here because i might be the
canadian who's won the most from a us
game show so we're trying to figure out
what that looks like i will keep you
posted that's crazy and how old was so
what you have now with survivor is you
have contestants on survivor who were a
generation of people who grew up with
survivor right we're in that period how
old were you when you started watching
survivor i was 11 years old wow absolute
madness so you are one you don't know
life without survivor basically it's so
weird it's crazy to think that i had
been dreaming about it since i was a kid
went on the show one what do i do next i
come here and i talk about it exactly